JENNY BROWN: Hi.
Today I'll be
talking to you about
an exciting new capability
Google Cloud has developed
called Apigee Adapter for Envoy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The goal of Apigee
Adapter for Envoy
is to help you integrate
Envoy-based services
into your Apigee environment.
This means you could do things
like publish your services
as APIs, make them visible
to other developers,
add governance capabilities to
control access to those APIs,
and analyze usage
metrics to see how
your APIs are being consumed.
Let's talk a little bit
more about how we do this.
Behind the scenes, Apigee
Adapter for Envoy boy
uses Envoy's external
authorization filter,
which is designed to allow
Envoy to delegate authorization
decisions to an external system.
In this demo, I'll
show you how to use
Envoy to protect an end point.
I'll add an Envoy
facade on it, which
is configured to talk to the
Apigee Adapter for Envoy.
Let's dive in.
I have an API product, which,
in Apigee, is the subscription
point or what
consumers subscribe to.
To begin with, I have nothing
configured in this API product.
The first step is to bind
the endpoint httpbin.org
to the API product.
With this command
I've just entered,
we have provided a
CLI, which allows
you to add the endpoint
httpbin.org to the product
httpbin.
When I refresh my
page, you'll see
the endpoint is bound to
the API product, httpbin.
Now we can turn our attention
to the components that are
going to run on my workstation.
I'll start with Analytics
which, is shipped by Apigee.
It gathers metrics
from Envoy that
measures the
consumption of the API,
such as the number
of successes, who's
been invoking APIs, et cetera.
I'm entering a
simple script that
starts the analytics
component of the adapter.
And the analytics
component is now running.
The next component I'm going
to start is Envoy itself.
Before I start Envoy, I
want to highlight two pieces
in the configuration--
the prefix and how
it handles requests.
I'll be matching
the prefix httpbin.
I'm configuring it
such that all requests
will pass through
the Envoy proxy
and go to the Apigee adapter.
The adapter will determine
whether the consumer has access
or not, and will reject
those that don't have access.
Let's go ahead and start Envoy.
So now I have the analytics
and Envoy components started.
The last component
that I need to start
is the Apigee adapter
for Envoy itself.
This is what advises Envoy
whether to allow or deny
a call.
And for that, I've
got a script here.
Now all three
components are running.
Let's try and access
the API endpoint get.
Because I don't have a
token, it didn't work
and the call was rejected.
Let me go and get the
token from Apigee.
Once I have the token,
I'll rerun the command
to access the API
endpoint, this time
by passing a token
as a parameter.
And this time around, I'm able
to access the API endpoint.
Now let's take a look at
what was in that token.
It has the audience,
remote service client.
It also indicates which products
the consumer can access.
In this case.
That's the product httpbin.
These elements were
then enforced by Envoy.
What I just showed you
is how an API consumer
would access this endpoint.
Another way this
could be done is
by publishing this endpoint
and a product on an API portal.
When developers come
to the API portal,
they can view and
access their APIs.
The API portal also allows
developers to grab credentials
for their httpbin product.
The credentials are masked
here for security purposes.
Once developers get
their credentials,
they can access the API,
like I showed earlier.
Through all these
interactions, analytics
are being collected
and transmitted
to the Apigee control panel.
Looking at API
metrics here, you'll
notice that httpbin.org
is getting requests,
and I can view
the data for that.
This is how you can use the
Apigee adapter for Envoy
to enforce policies for any
service that's using Envoy.
Now that you know how it
works and what it does,
let me talk to you about how
to start using the Apigee
adapter for Envoy.
The easiest way
to get started is
from our Docs page, which
I've linked in the description
for this video.
That's where we've outlined
three examples that you
can follow to get started--
native Envoy with Apigee
Edge for public cloud,
Istio side car
with Apigee hybrid,
and native Envoy with
Apigee for private cloud.
The Apigee adapter
for Envoy can also
be used by anyone who uses Istio
or Google Anthos service mesh.
To get started with those, get
in touch with your Google Cloud
account team.
In summary, the Apigee
adapter for Envoy
gives you an easy way to plug
API management capabilities,
such as publishing, visibility,
governance, and usage
analytics, into those
services that require them.
Links to more information,
like code labs and blog posts,
are in the description below.
And be sure to check
out our other videos
and let us know what else you'd
like to learn about Apigee.
[MUSIC PLAYING]